يتقدم الهجوم المضاد الطاحن الذي تشنه أوكرانيا
ضد روسيا نحو الأمام ويحقق
مكاسب بطيئة ولكن تدريجية، وتزعم كييف أن
قواتها تعزز مواقعها وتستعيد
السيطرة على قرية شرقية جنوبية في منطقة دونيتسك.
المرافق في
الجنوب، يأتي ذلك في الوقت الذي غادرت فيه سفينة شحن
ميناء أوديسا الرئيسي على البحر الأسود
للمرة الأولى منذ أن تخلت روسيا عن
صفقة الحبوب التي توسطت فيها الأمم المتحدة الشهر الماضي،
تنضم إليّ البشير الآن نادية،
فلنعد إلى هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار
وتأثيرها.  لدينا أيضًا ما هي الأخبار التي يجب
عليك مشاركتها حول
الاكتفاء الذاتي المحتمل لروسيا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالطائرات بدون طيار، لقد رأينا
القوات المسلحة الروسية تعتمد بشكل كبير على
هجمات الطائرات بدون طيار هذه خاصة خلال
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ومنذ فشل صفقة الحبوب هذه
بالفعل  خلال الشهر الماضي،
شهدنا هجمات متكررة بطائرات بدون طيار
ضد ميناء أوديسا
والبنية التحتية الأخرى للموانئ عبر تلك المنطقة،
ولكننا الآن نتعلم من
معلومات استخباراتية جديدة من وزارة الدفاع البريطانية
أنهم يعتقدون أن
روسيا يمكن أن تضمن
الاكتفاء الذاتي في الأشهر المقبلة.  على هذه الجبهة الآن، بالنسبة
للجزء الرئيسي، كانوا يعتمدون على
طائرات بدون طيار إيرانية الصنع، وبدأوا في
استيراد هذه الطائرات بدون طيار في العام الماضي، ولكن
وفقًا لوزارة الدفاع البريطانية،
يعتقدون الآن أنهم بدأوا في
نشر طائرات بدون طيار منتجة محليًا
استنادًا إلى نموذج تلك الطائرات الإيرانية.  صنعت
طائرة بدون طيار من طراز Sharehid الآن، وهذا
التصنيع المحلي لهذه الطائرات بدون طيار سيمنح
روسيا الاكتفاء الذاتي
على تلك الجبهة والذي يُعتقد أنه سيكون
الهدف خلال الأشهر القليلة المقبلة على الرغم من أنهم
في هذه المرحلة ما زالوا يعتمدون على
تلك الطائرات بدون طيار الإيرانية الصنع وأيضًا على
المكونات و  أسلحة أخرى من
شركائهم وحلفائهم في الخارج وبالطبع
رأينا أنه في
الهجمات الصاروخية عبر أوكرانيا
بالأمس فقط سمعنا من
المسؤولين الأوكرانيين أنهم عثروا على 30
سفينة أجنبية داخل صواريخ روسية الصنع
ورأوا صواريخ
يعتقدون أنها كانت كذلك.  تم تصنيعها داخل روسيا
في الأشهر القليلة الماضية فقط، لذا فإن هذا يمثل مصدر
قلق كبير. وتدعو أوكرانيا إلى اتخاذ
إجراءات أكثر صرامة وعقوبات أكثر صرامة
لضمان
عدم وصول التكنولوجيا الأجنبية إلى أيدي الروس.